you make a great Point there's a lot of
things in our lives that we
subconsciously make Idols in our lives
where we spend so much time in it around
it that it takes over our brain and so
when crypto came about my major issue
with crypto was not that you're going to
lose a bunch of money that's a
possibility my issue with crypto was
that it was 24 7 and you can just see on
your app at volatility all day long and
it was so many it was new coins there
was Community groups all about it and
you could just have it consume your life
and that's why I joked that crypto is
just you know Mary Kay for young men
because there was this obsessive nature
just like there is with multi of
multi-level marketing where people were
just it took over their life it became a
personality trait and that's where I go
let's draw a line here it's great to
enjoy something it's not great to be
consumed by it that turns into an
addiction